il en a fait l'annonce hier soir à nos
confrères de France 3 wilfridge Schwartz
l'ancien maire de La Riche a décidé de
se retirer temporairement de la vie
politique locale l'ancien président de
Tours métropole toujours conseillers
municipal et conseillé départemental
devrait abandonner ces derniers mandats
l'affaire dite de la gifle là finalement
eu raison de ses ambitions politiques
les explications du principal intéressé
interrogé par Romain Delville
redevenu employé à plein temps de
l'Université de Tours depuis le mois de
décembre Wilfrid Schwartz a décidé
d'abandonner son pourvoi en cassation se
plie à la condamnation d'inel
éligibilité de 6 mois dans l'affaire de
la gifle et par voie de conséquences
perd toute fonction politique cette
décision je l'ai prise
pendant cet hiver pendant la période des
congés de Noël en particulier avec mes
proches ma famille que j'ai senti
particulièrement heurté depuis ses
nombreux mois au coeur de la polémique
et je me suis dit
j'étais pas j'avais plus envie de
continuer
pendant encore peut-être un an un an et
demi sur sur cette histoire là j'ai
envie de tourner la page sincèrement
ancien maire de La Riche ancien
président de la métropole de Tours et on
voit de laisser sa place de conseiller
départemental à son remplaçant le
trentenaire réfléchit à s'engager
autrement tout ceci c'est malgré moi
j'ai pas le choix j'ai toujours envie
d'être là pour les gens je trouverai
d'autres façons de m'impliquer
dans le milieu associatif le fait déjà
j'ai longtemps été plus plus engagé à
militants avant d'être un élu donc je
resterai toujours dans cette dans cette
philosophie là ça ça changera pas c'est
une décision judiciaire qui met fin au
mandat de Wilfrid Schwartz mais
politiquement sa situation depuis sa
condamnation était devenue si ce n'est
intenable tout du moins très compliqué
en effet il a été élu président de la
métropole avec le soutien de la gauche
avec le soutien de la mairie de Tours du
maire de balance IR il s'est présenté au
départemental avec une conseillère
municipale de Ballan-Miré Solène
marchand puis est arrivé cette histoire
de la gifle il a été il a quitté son
poste de président de la tour métropole
il est resté dans l'exécutif cette fois
avec le soutien de la droite avec
Philippe Briand on sait qu'il reste
influent dans le territoire avec
Frédéric rogis le nouveau président de
ton métropole qui publiquement à
maintenu son sa confiance son soutien
tout ça jusqu'au procès en appel ou là
pour le coup wilfrieds a perdu les
derniers soutiens politiques qu'il avait
c'est un chapitre politique qui se ferme
pour Wilfrid Schwartz mais il ne
souhaite pas abandonner la politique
définitivement en rappelant qu'il n'a
que 37 ans